uh this made my position clear to a woke  friend  children as a group are sexually abused  by adults as a group  therefore all adults harbor internalized  pedophilia  any denial of this assertion is  pedophile fragility  that's pretty darn good that's really  good yeah that's really good  well done i'm gonna say it again because  uh although maybe this should be  clipped but this this is this is snowden  bleep  who who brings this to us um snowden  bleep's  strategy is saying this to a friend who  is woke children as a group are sexually  abused by adults as a group  therefore all adults must harbor  internalized pedophilia any denial of  this assertion  is pedophile fragility so good yeah  that's really that's awesome keep doing  that yeah that's right  you